he's rook and then he'll pounce with
this really nasty check
wow clever idea right that is sneaky
david and look at that
the knight has been forced to retreat
all the way back wow look at this
the bar's gone to plus eight for white
he can actually completely destroy
wesley so now the white queen's gone on
the attack
checkmate's coming yeah i mean the big
threat is actually to jump in with the
knight
to the f6 square and then it will be
mate
unstoppable um okay is there anything
else that
uh wesley can do to stop one of the
white's knights
jumping in no there's nothing um
not only that but white rook is
threatening to come up and take a pawn
uh attacking the black queen both of the
white knights are jumping in white is
attacking with a queen
two knights a bishop and a rook black's
just defending with one night
and the bad news for wesley is we're
only on move 17.
this is gonna be in the miniature
history books
we've never seen wesley crushed like
this
17 moves flat completely flattened
wow is this jordan forest he was a big
underdog he is a big underdog in this
quarterfinal matchup
he uh impressed us in the first game
with the black pieces this is just
incredible stuff
okay well we have some moves he's
actually taken the pawn with a bishop
and now jordan van forest knight has
come
forward threatening mate bishop
retweeted and knight takes pawn and
is wesley about to resign body language
wow
wow what a shocking result in the second
game
in the quarterfinals you're in front
forest